- Bienvenido de nuevo a Entendiendo la Información y la Computación Cuántica.
Mi nombre es John Watrous y soy el Director Técnico de
Educación en IBM Quantum.
Esta es la séptima lección de la serie y en ella hablaremos sobre el problema de estimación de fase y cómo podemos resolverlo
con una computadora cuántica.
Luego aplicaremos la estimación de fase al problema de la factorización de enteros, que discutimos en la lección anterior.
Lo que obtendremos es el algoritmo de Shor, que permite factorizar enteros
a costo polinomial o en tiempo polinomial si preferimos
pensar en términos del tiempo requerido en lugar del número de
operaciones elementales que necesitamos.
Esta es la joya de la corona de
los algoritmos cuánticos en cierto sentido, y aunque factorizar enteros grandes
puede tener una utilidad limitada para la mayoría de las personas, sigue siendo una de las evidencias más
convincentes que tenemos a favor de la hipótesis de que las computadoras cuánticas ofrecerán ventajas notables
sobre las computadoras clásicas. Aquí tienes un resumen de la lección.
Comenzaremos con una definición del propio problema de estimación de fase, y luego discutiremos un método para resolver este problema
con una computadora cuántica.
Lo haremos paso a paso, comenzando con lo que puedes
pensar como una especie de calentamiento.
En el problema de estimación de fase, el objetivo es aproximar
cierto número real y en esta parte de calentamiento
veremos cómo podemos obtener
una aproximación de muy baja precisión
a este número.
Esto no va a ser
suficiente para la factorización cuando apliquemos nuestra solución
al problema de estimación de fase a la factorización de enteros,
en realidad vamos a necesitar una aproximación de bastante alta precisión, pero aun así es útil comenzar con este tipo de calentamiento
solo para tener una idea de
cómo funciona todo.
Luego discutiremos el tema de cómo podemos obtener más precisión, y esto nos llevará muy
naturalmente a una operación conocida como la Transformada de Fourier Cuántica.
Veremos exactamente en qué consiste esta operación y cómo puede implementarse
con un quantum circuit.
Y una vez que la tengamos, podremos aplicarla
a la estimación de fase para obtener un procedimiento general para resolver el problema
con muy alta precisión.
Luego, en la última parte de la lección, veremos cómo una solución al
problema de estimación de fase nos permite factorizar enteros de manera eficiente.
Y específicamente lo que obtendremos es el algoritmo de Shor para
la factorización de enteros, o al menos algo equivalente al algoritmo de Shor.
La forma en que esto funciona es que básicamente nos damos
un escalón intermedio, que es otro problema llamado el problema de búsqueda de orden.
En particular, veremos cómo podemos resolver el problema de búsqueda de orden usando el procedimiento de estimación de fase y luego veremos cómo
podemos factorizar enteros
resolviendo el problema de búsqueda de orden. Vamos a comenzar con un caso especial de un teorema llamado el Teorema Espectral,
y específicamente nos vamos a centrar en lo que el teorema nos dice
sobre las matrices unitarias.
El teorema espectral es
un teorema muy importante del álgebra lineal y el
análisis funcional.
Nos dice algo interesante sobre cómo ciertas aplicaciones lineales pueden expresarse de una forma determinada, que a menudo se llama
descomposición espectral,
que es útil por muchas razones.
Y como dije, nos vamos a centrar en lo que este teorema nos dice
sobre las matrices unitarias.
El teorema espectral es
más general que esto. No funciona para todas las matrices, pero sí funciona para una clase de matrices
llamadas matrices normales, que incluyen todas las matrices unitarias así como algunas matrices
que no son unitarias.
Pero para simplificar las cosas, restringiremos nuestra atención
a las matrices unitarias por ahora, ya que es todo lo que necesitamos para
los propósitos de esta lección.
Aquí tienes un enunciado del teorema espectral solo para matrices unitarias.
Supongamos que U es una
matriz unitaria N por N.
Lo que dice el teorema
es que debe existir una base ortonormal de
vectores, psi uno hasta psi N,
junto con N números complejos
Lambda uno hasta Lambda N, todos situados sobre el círculo unitario complejo, de modo que U puede expresarse
como tenemos en esta ecuación.
Esto se llama una descomposición
espectral de U, como ya mencioné, y puede ser muy conveniente saber que U puede escribirse de esta manera.
A veces puede ser conveniente tener estos vectores y estos números cuando trabajamos con
una matriz unitaria U en particular, y también puede ser muy
útil simplemente saber
que dicha expresión siempre es posible como una manera de demostrar ciertas cosas sobre las matrices unitarias, por ejemplo.
En este enunciado del teorema, cada uno de estos números,
Lambda uno hasta lambda N, se escribe de una manera particular
como E elevado a la potencia dos pi I veces theta, donde cada uno de los thetas
theta uno hasta theta N es un número real, y
volveremos a esta forma
de escribir cada uno de estos
números en un momento.
Una cosa importante que hay que notar
sobre estos vectores y números es que cada vector psi
K debe ser un vector propio de la matriz U con
valor propio correspondiente lambda K.
Lo que significa que si
multiplicamos psi K por U, lo que obtenemos es lambda K por psi K.
Entonces lo que U hace a cada uno de estos vectores es simplemente multiplicarlo por el número correspondiente lambda K.
En general, para algún vector arbitrario, esta no será la forma en que U funciona, pero los vectores propios son especiales.
Y lo que el teorema nos dice es que de hecho existe
una base ortonormal de estos vectores propios.
Esta ecuación de aquí abajo, por cierto, se desprende de la expresión que tenemos para U del teorema, junto con el hecho de que
los vectores son ortonormales.
Si multiplicas la expresión de U por cualquier psi K y usas la ortonormalidad de los vectores, obtendrás una suma en la que
todos los términos son cero
excepto uno de ellos, y el único término que
nos queda tiene este aspecto.
Ahora podemos definir el
problema de estimación de fase.
El problema es un poco
inusual, como veremos.
Se nos dan dos cosas. Primero, se nos da la descripción de un quantum circuit unitario,
que actúa sobre N qubits
para alguna elección de N, y cuando decimos que
este es un circuit unitario,
simplemente queremos decir que todos los
gates son unitarios, así que no hay mediciones
en este circuit.
Segundo, se nos da un estado psi de N qubits, y esa es la parte inusual.
En realidad tenemos una entrada de estado cuántico para este problema, y es una sola copia de ese estado.
Para todos los demás problemas computacionales de los que hemos hablado en esta serie, la entrada ha sido clásica, ya sea en forma de una cadena
de bits o como una caja negra.
Y eso no es sorprendente porque los problemas computacionales que encontramos en nuestra vida diaria tienden a ser clásicos,
ya que esos son los
problemas que más nos importan.
La forma en que puedes
pensar en este problema es que es algo que aparece o es probable que aparezca como un subproblema.
Y el procedimiento de estimación de fase que eventualmente desarrollaremos es algo que
generalmente usamos como una subrutina
dentro de algún cálculo más grande, presumiblemente uno para un problema clásico
que nos importa.
Ahora bien, este va a ser un problema con promesa y el estado psi no es
cualquier estado cuántico.
Se nos promete que psi es un vector propio de cualquier operación unitaria U que describa el circuit dado.
Y el objetivo es encontrar o
aproximar el valor propio que corresponde al vector propio psi.
Planteemos el problema de forma
un poco más precisa.
La entrada consiste en un quantum circuit
unitario sobre N qubits, que puede codificarse como una cadena de bits
usando el método que prefiramos para codificar descripciones de quantum circuits, junto con un estado psi de N qubits.
Podemos llamar al circuit como queramos, pero lo que realmente importa en cuanto al enunciado de este problema es la propia operación unitaria
que se realiza cuando se ejecuta el circuit, y esa operación unitaria
está descrita por la matriz U.
Pero no se nos da U como una matriz, solo se nos da la descripción de un quantum circuit que implementa U.
La promesa, como ya he indicado, es que psi es un vector propio de U.
Así que si ejecutáramos nuestro circuit sobre psi, obtendríamos psi a la salida multiplicado por cualquiera que sea el valor propio,
lo que sería una fase global
en esa situación.
Y finalmente, la salida del problema es una aproximación al valor propio correspondiente a psi, y específicamente buscamos
una aproximación al número real theta, entre cero y uno, incluyendo
cero, pero sin incluir uno
que satisface la ecuación
que tenemos en pantalla.
Para explicar esta forma de
parametrizar el valor propio correspondiente a psi, y también para aclarar qué entendemos por aproximación,
dibujemos una imagen del
círculo unitario complejo.
Podemos colocar los números uno, i,
menos uno y menos i en sus lugares habituales y podemos considerar
algún punto arbitrario en el
círculo parametrizado por theta como tenemos en el enunciado del problema.
Este es el punto que
obtenemos si empezamos en uno y rotamos un ángulo de
dos veces pi veces theta, así que el ángulo no es
theta, sino dos pi theta,
y otra forma de pensarlo es que si empezamos en uno y recorremos una distancia de dos pi theta sobre el propio círculo,
llegaremos a nuestro punto, e elevado a
dos veces pi veces theta.
Cada punto del círculo unitario complejo puede representarse de esta forma
para una elección única de theta.
Y eso es porque damos
toda la vuelta al círculo cuando theta va de cero a uno, y si llegáramos hasta
theta igual a uno,
estaríamos de vuelta donde
empezamos en theta igual a cero, por eso incluimos cero, pero no incluimos uno.
Solo para asegurarnos de que cada
punto del círculo unitario complejo corresponde a un valor único de theta en el rango que estamos considerando.
Hay varias formas en que podríamos imaginar aproximar un valor particular de theta, pero la forma en que lo haremos es aproximar theta con una fracción,
donde el denominador
es dos elevado a la potencia M para alguna elección de un entero positivo M, y el numerador es un entero y
entre cero y dos elevado a M menos uno.
Puedes pensar en esto como una aproximación de M bits a theta si quieres, y podríamos escribir este
número en notación binaria
donde tenemos un punto binario seguido de la representación binaria
de Y.
Digo punto binario y no
punto decimal porque decimal significa base 10 y estoy hablando de base dos
aquí, pero es la misma idea.
Pero en cualquier caso también podemos
simplemente pensarlo como una fracción tal como
aparece en pantalla.
Y para ser claros, cuando pensamos en
aproximaciones en este contexto, hay que entender
que los valores de theta
cercanos a cero y los valores de theta cercanos a uno están de hecho muy próximos entre sí.
Así que, por ejemplo, si theta es igual a 0.99 y aproximamos este valor
de theta por el valor cero,
eso es una aproximación bastante buena, en el sentido de que está
dentro de una centésima del valor real, cuando
damos la vuelta al círculo
y volvemos a cero cuando llegamos a uno.
El término módulo uno se usa a veces para describir la situación en la que básicamente
igualamos theta igual a uno con theta igual a cero.
La cuestión es que lo que realmente nos importa es la ubicación del punto
E a la dos pi I theta en el círculo unitario,
y pensar en esta
forma de aproximar theta tiene sentido cuando tenemos ese objetivo en mente.
El enunciado del problema en sí,
tal como aparece en pantalla, no especifica qué tan buena debe ser la aproximación a theta,
pero eso es algo que podemos ajustar según nuestras necesidades.
En algunas situaciones podríamos conformarnos con una aproximación
de baja precisión a theta, y en otras situaciones podríamos exigir
una aproximación de muy alta precisión, y el enunciado del problema en sí
puede refinarse en consecuencia.
A continuación veremos cómo podemos resolver
el problema de estimación de fase con un ordenador cuántico y
comenzaremos con un ejercicio de calentamiento.
Esta no será nuestra solución
definitiva al problema.
Lo que haremos es aprovechar el fenómeno de phase kickback para intentar aprender algo
sobre el valor propio correspondiente a un vector propio dado.
Recuerda que en el
problema de estimación de fase se nos da la descripción
de un quantum circuit unitario para cierta operación U,
y lo primero que hacemos es usar
esta descripción del circuit para crear un nuevo circuit que implemente una operación U controlada, como
se muestra en pantalla.
Esto es bastante sencillo de hacer. Lo que podemos hacer es añadir un qubit de control, que se muestra
arriba en este diagrama,
y usar este nuevo qubit de
control como control para cada gate
que aparece en nuestro circuit.
Así que todos los gates se aplican si este qubit de control está en uno, y ninguno se aplica si el qubit de control está en cero,
lo que significa que vamos a necesitar
una versión controlada de cada gate que
aparece en el circuit U, pero no tenemos que pensar
en estos nuevos gates controlados
como gates individuales si no queremos. Podrían implementarse
como pequeños circuits formados por gates del conjunto de gates
que hayamos elegido usar. Y una vez que tenemos una
versión controlada de U, podemos considerar ejecutar este circuit,
donde primero ponemos el qubit de control en una superposición de cero y uno, aplicamos el gate U controlado al estado del vector propio que nos dan,
y luego aplicamos un gate Hadamard
al control y medimos.
Veremos por qué tiene sentido hacer esto a medida que avancemos en el análisis, pero incluso antes de entrar en los detalles, podemos ver de inmediato una similitud
con el algoritmo de Deutsch, por ejemplo, donde aplicamos
un par de gates Hadamard y medimos como forma
de explorar eficazmente
qué es lo que hace aquí
una operación dada.
Es una unitaria controlada
en lugar de un gate de consulta, pero hay ideas muy similares en juego.
Así que veamos qué hace el circuit.
El estado inicial es el vector propio psi, aplicado en tensorial con el estado cero
del qubit de control,
aplicar el primer gate Hadamard transforma el estado del
qubit superior a un estado más, y podemos expandir el estado completo
como se muestra aquí.
Luego aplicamos la operación U controlada, que lo que hace es aplicar U a psi cuando el qubit de control está en uno,
pero no cuando está en cero. Así que obtenemos el estado pi dos
que se muestra en pantalla.
Podemos simplificar el estado
usando el hecho de que psi es un vector propio de U con valor propio e a la dos pi I theta.
Así obtenemos ese valor propio multiplicando el segundo
término, pero no el primero.
Y podemos simplificar usando la bilinealidad
del producto tensorial.
Lo que tenemos aquí es el fenómeno de phase kickback, pero esta vez ocurre para algún vector propio psi arbitrario de alguna operación unitaria U arbitraria,
a diferencia de una operación NOT aplicada a un estado menos, más concretamente.
Ese es el estado después de aplicar la operación U controlada.
Por cierto, vale la pena
tomarse un momento para notar que el estado de los N qubits inferiores sigue siendo el vector propio psi.
Lo cual es genial porque eso
nos da la oportunidad de volver a usarlo si así lo decidimos.
Luego se aplica el segundo gate Hadamard y aquí está el estado que obtenemos.
No he mostrado todos los
detalles de la derivación aquí, pero si aplicas el
gate Hadamard y simplificas, esto es lo que deberías obtener.
Ese es el estado justo
antes de la medición.
Así que podemos centrarnos en este estado para ver qué podemos aprender
sobre theta al medir.
Y si medimos el qubit
superior, o el qubit más a la derecha, estas son las probabilidades que obtenemos para los dos resultados.
Y aquí he usado un
par de fórmulas básicas que relacionan senos y cosenos
con exponenciales complejas para expresar estas probabilidades
en términos de senos y cosenos.
Concretamente, la probabilidad de obtener cero es el coseno al cuadrado de pi por theta y la probabilidad de obtener uno
es el seno al cuadrado del mismo ángulo. Y esto tiene sentido
porque el seno al cuadrado más el coseno al cuadrado de
cualquier ángulo es igual a uno.
Así que nuestras probabilidades
suman uno, como esperamos.
Y aquí hay un gráfico de estas probabilidades como función de theta.
Para ser precisos, este es un gráfico de
las probabilidades en sí mismas, a diferencia de un gráfico que representa una única distribución
de probabilidad, por ejemplo.
Por ejemplo, si theta
es igual a un medio, entonces la probabilidad de
obtener el resultado uno, que se muestra en morado, es igual a uno
mientras que la probabilidad
de obtener el resultado cero, que se muestra en azul, es cero.
Por otro lado, si theta es igual a un
cuarto o tres cuartos, entonces cada uno de los dos resultados es igualmente probable.
Y por supuesto, para todas las elecciones de theta, la suma de las probabilidades es igual a uno, como ya hemos observado.
Así que no aprendemos exactamente cuál es
theta con este procedimiento, pero sí nos da algo de
información sobre theta.
Y si imaginamos una situación en la que se nos garantiza
que theta es igual a cero o theta es igual a un medio, este procedimiento nos dirá
exactamente cuál de las
dos posibilidades es.
Así que esa es una manera sencilla en la que podemos usar el fenómeno de phase kickback para aprender algo sobre el valor propio.
¿Entonces cómo podemos aprender más
sobre el valor propio?
Bueno, esta es una situación en la que podemos dejar
que la ignorancia nos guíe.
Porque realmente no hay
muchas cosas que podamos hacer.
No sabemos casi nada
sobre el vector propio psi, y tampoco sabemos
mucho sobre la operación U.
Tenemos un circuit para U, pero por lo que sabemos podría ser
un desastre horrible y confuso del que no seríamos capaces de
sacar ningún sentido con solo examinarlo.
Pero una opción natural es ejecutar el circuit varias veces.
En particular, podríamos intentar hacer exactamente lo mismo que acabamos de hacer, salvo que en lugar de aplicar una sola operación U controlada,
aplicamos esa operación dos veces. O podríamos aplicarla cualquier número de veces, pero empecemos con dos
solo para ver qué pasa.
Bueno, en realidad es bastante
simple lo que ocurre. Al aplicar la operación U
controlada dos veces, básicamente estamos
elevando al cuadrado el valor propio
porque se introducirá en
la fase del qubit superior dos veces en lugar de una sola.
Y así, cuando pensamos en
las probabilidades de los resultados como función de theta, básicamente estamos
duplicando la frecuencia.
Para cada posible elección de theta, las probabilidades de los resultados
son las mismas que si duplicáramos theta y luego
tomáramos la parte fraccionaria
para obtener un número entre cero y uno.
Por ejemplo, si theta
es igual a un medio, entonces el valor propio es menos uno.
Entonces, al aplicar U dos veces, básicamente estamos elevando al cuadrado el valor propio y el resultado es el mismo que para theta igual a cero.
Es decir, que la probabilidad
para el resultado cero, mostrada en azul, es igual a uno, y la probabilidad para el resultado uno, mostrada en morado, es igual a cero.
Esto es muy sencillo, pero en realidad podemos obtener
algo de información adicional sobre theta haciendo esto.
Por ejemplo, si sabemos de antemano que theta es igual a cero o theta es igual a un cuarto, entonces este circuit nos revelará
cuál de las dos posibilidades es.
Por otro lado, ya no podemos distinguir el caso en que theta es igual a cero del caso en que theta es igual a un medio.
Así que este procedimiento no es estrictamente mejor que el anterior, cuando
teníamos un solo gate U controlado, pero también ejecutando este circuit
podemos obtener información adicional.
No está del todo claro de inmediato
cómo la información adicional que podemos obtener iterando la operación U controlada varias veces
puede reconciliarse con
la información que obtenemos al realizarla solo una vez, y de hecho hay múltiples
maneras de proceder.
Por ejemplo, existe una técnica llamada estimación de fase iterativa, que consiste en ejecutar circuits como los que hemos visto,
junto con algunas variaciones menores sobre ellos, para llegar a una aproximación de theta.
Pero voy a describir
lo que podría llamarse un enfoque más tradicional, donde usamos un único quantum circuit que tiene múltiples qubits de control
que controlan distintos
números de iteraciones de la operación unitaria U.
Primero describiré cómo funciona esto
con dos qubits de control y luego, un poco más adelante, lo generalizaremos a más de dos qubits de control.
Aquí hay un quantum circuit
que usa dos qubits de control.
El qubit de control superior
controla una única operación U, mientras que el segundo qubit
desde arriba controla dos copias de U.
Así que lo que estamos haciendo es combinar los dos circuits que vimos antes, de manera que se aproveche la única copia
del vector propio psi que tenemos.
Sin embargo, notarás
que los gates Hadamard después de las operaciones U
controladas han sido eliminados y todavía no hay mediciones.
Lo que vamos a hacer es
ver cómo funciona este circuit y luego descubrir
qué debemos hacer con los dos qubits superiores
para aprender lo más posible sobre el valor theta que
estamos intentando aproximar.
Después de que se realizan los gates Hadamard, teníamos el estado que se
muestra en pantalla.
Y esta va a ser una forma conveniente de escribir el estado para
ver qué sucede a continuación.
A cero y A uno son bits, y si pensamos en los dos qubits superiores como un registro de dos qubits,
estamos pensando en A cero, que corresponde al qubit superior como el bit menos significativo, y A uno que corresponde
al qubit de control inferior
como el bit más significativo.
Después de que se realiza la primera operación
U controlada, obtenemos este estado.
El estado clásico correspondiente al qubit de control superior es cero, así que el resultado del phase kickback
puede expresarse de esta manera. Luego, después de la segunda y
la tercera operación U controlada,
se realizan, obtenemos este estado.
La idea es la misma que para la primera, excepto que esta vez estamos aplicando la operación U de control dos veces.
Así que multiplicamos A uno por dos en
el exponente para reflejar esto.
Y ahora podemos simplificar esta expresión pensando en los bits
A uno y A cero juntos como un entero entre cero y
tres usando notación binaria.
Es decir, cuando pensamos
en la cadena de dos bits, A uno A cero, como la codificación
binaria de un entero,
lo que obtenemos es dos
veces A uno más A cero.
Y se entiende que
cuando escribimos Cat X, estamos hablando de X escrito como una cadena binaria de longitud
dos usando notación binaria.
Entonces ahora enfoquémonos en
estos dos qubits de control para descubrir qué podemos
aprender sobre theta a partir de ellos en este punto.
Los N qubits restantes todavía están
en el mismo estado psi que nos dieron originalmente, lo cual es verdaderamente algo maravilloso
de este enfoque,
porque, como dije antes, podemos usar ese estado de nuevo si queremos obtener aún más
información sobre theta.
Pero por ahora, pensemos simplemente en qué podemos aprender a partir de
estos dos qubits de control.
Para ayudarnos a determinar cómo proceder, imaginemos que se nos promete que theta es igual a Y sobre cuatro
para algún entero y entre cero y tres.
En general, theta puede que no
sea uno de estos cuatro valores, pero es un caso natural a considerar.
Vimos en la versión original con un solo qubit de control del procedimiento que, si se nos prometía que theta es cero o un medio,
el circuit revelaría cuál era. Y también notamos que en la versión donde aplicábamos la operación
U controlada dos veces,
podíamos discriminar perfectamente el caso en que theta es igual a cero del caso en que theta
es igual a un cuarto.
Así que podríamos esperar que con nuestro nuevo circuit podamos discriminar estos cuatro casos.
En esencia, lo que estamos
haciendo es usar la noción de un problema de promesa
para hacer el problema más fácil, de modo que podamos ver cómo proceder.
Y eso no es mala idea en general. Si tienes un problema y
no sabes cómo resolverlo, intenta hacerlo más fácil.
Si puedes resolver el problema más fácil, la comprensión que obtienes podría ser útil para resolver el problema más general.
Y si no puedes resolver el problema más fácil, probablemente no estás listo
para el problema más general.
Así que sigue haciéndolo más fácil
hasta que puedas resolverlo.
De todas formas, volviendo a nuestro problema, definamos un estado de dos qubits para cada uno de los posibles valores de Y.
En otras palabras, phi Y es igual al estado
que se muestra en la parte superior de la pantalla cuando theta se elige
específicamente como Y sobre cuatro.
Y aquí están esos cuatro
estados escritos explícitamente.
Para reiterar, si
theta es igual a Y sobre cuatro con Y siendo cero, uno, dos o
tres, y ejecutamos nuestro circuit,
vamos a quedarnos con
uno de estos cuatro estados, el que corresponda
al valor correcto de Y.
Y solo queremos descubrir
cuál es.
Y la pregunta es: ¿es esto posible?
Y la respuesta a esa pregunta es sí, porque estos cuatro estados son ortogonales.
Si calculas el producto interno
entre cualquier par de ellos, obtendrás cero.
Y como son ortogonales, pueden ser discriminados perfectamente mediante una medición proyectiva.
Y en particular podemos
expresar dicha medición definiendo una proyección para cada vector, como tenemos aquí.
Esto siempre funciona: siempre que
tengamos una base ortonormal, y puedes comprobarlo
con las definiciones que vimos en la lección tres
para este caso específico,
si te apetece hacerlo. Así que concluimos que sí es
posible lograr nuestra tarea,
que es aprender el valor de Y a partir del estado que se muestra
en la parte superior de la pantalla.
Y si queremos hacer eso
con un quantum circuit, podemos proceder como explicaré ahora.
Primero podemos definir una matriz unitaria V cuyas columnas son los cuatro
vectores listados en orden.
Esa matriz tendrá la acción descrita en la parte inferior de la pantalla,
sobre los estados de la base estándar,
y podemos escribir la matriz
para ver cómo se ve.
Dado que V mapea cada estado de la base estándar, kappa Y al vector phi Y, tenemos que al aplicar V dagger,
o en otras palabras V inversa a phi Y, se transforma de vuelta al estado de la base estándar correspondiente.
Así que lo que podemos hacer es aplicar V dagger al estado que
obtuvimos de nuestro circuit.
Y luego, si realizamos una
medición en la base estándar, obtendremos el número Y
que estamos buscando, expresado como una cadena
de longitud dos en binario.
Antes de continuar, hablemos un poco más
sobre la matriz unitaria V.
Esta es una matriz especial y
puede que ya la hayas visto antes.
Es la matriz asociada
con una operación lineal sobre vectores de cuatro dimensiones conocida como la transformada de Fourier discreta.
Para ser más precisos, la transformada de Fourier discreta se puede definir para cualquier
entero positivo de dimensión, y la veremos
en general en unos momentos.
Y esto es lo que
parece específicamente cuando la dimensión es igual a cuatro.
Podemos pensar en la
transformada de Fourier discreta de distintas maneras.
Podemos pensarla de forma puramente abstracta como una aplicación lineal sobre vectores que puede representarse mediante una matriz.
Y también podemos pensarla como
un problema computacional en el que se nos da un vector y queremos calcular el resultado
de aplicar esta aplicación lineal.
Resulta ser un problema computacional
increíblemente importante, y existe un algoritmo muy eficiente para realizar ese cálculo
conocido como la transformada rápida de Fourier.
De hecho, este es un problema tan importante en el procesamiento de señales, por ejemplo, que la transformada rápida
de Fourier es considerada por muchos
como uno de los algoritmos más importantes
y trascendentales jamás descubiertos.
También podemos pensar en la
transformada de Fourier discreta como una operación cuántica unitaria que se puede aplicar a
un vector de estado cuántico.
Y cuando la pensamos de esa manera, la llamamos la transformada de Fourier
cuántica, o QFT por sus siglas en inglés.
Matemáticamente hablando, es esencialmente lo mismo que la transformada de Fourier discreta, pero la llamamos la
transformada de Fourier cuántica
solo para aclarar que es una operación que se aplica a un vector de estado cuántico.
Así que cambiemos el nombre de nuestra matriz, de V a QFT cuatro, para reflejar el hecho
de que la operación que hemos obtenido es en realidad la transformada de Fourier cuántica.
Aquí está el circuit completo para aprender el valor de Y cuando se nos promete que
theta es igual a Y dividido entre cuatro
para Y siendo cero, uno, dos o tres.
Y solo para asegurarnos de que quede claro, estamos aplicando la inversa de
la transformada de Fourier cuántica, o en otras palabras QFT cuatro dagger,
para mapear uno de los cuatro estados posibles de vuelta al estado de la base estándar, ket Y, de modo que podamos recuperar Y midiendo.
Así que ese es el circuit que
obtenemos al pensar en la versión prometida del
problema de estimación de fase, donde se nos promete que theta
es cero, un cuarto, un
medio o tres cuartos, pero no hay nada que nos impida
ejecutar este circuit para
un valor arbitrario de theta.
Y si lo hacemos, aquí
están las probabilidades de los cuatro posibles
resultados que obtenemos.
Cada uno de los cuatro posibles
valores de Y tiene su propio color, y la gráfica nos dice
cuáles son las probabilidades de cada uno en función de theta.
Por ejemplo, si theta
es igual a tres cuartos, obtendremos el resultado
tres con probabilidad uno,
mientras que las probabilidades de los otros tres resultados son todas cero, como ya sabemos al pensar en la versión prometida del problema.
Si theta es cercano a tres cuartos pero no exactamente tres cuartos, habrá alguna probabilidad no nula asociada con los otros resultados,
pero aun así obtendremos el resultado
tres con alta probabilidad.
Así que aunque theta puede
no ser igual a Y dividido entre cuatro, aún podemos pensar
en el resultado que obtenemos de las mediciones dividido entre cuatro
como una estimación o una
aproximación de theta.
La estimación puede ser incorrecta, pero de todas formas nos está
proporcionando información.
Y algo que podemos
aprender de la gráfica es que las mejores aproximaciones siempre tienen las
probabilidades más altas asociadas a ellas.
Cuando digo la mejor aproximación, me refiero a cualquier valor de Y dividido entre cuatro que esté más cercano al valor real de theta,
en el sentido modular uno. El peor caso posible es que theta esté exactamente a la mitad entre
dos valores de Y dividido entre cuatro.
Por ejemplo, si theta es igual
a tres octavos o 0.375, en este caso vemos
que las aproximaciones
un cuarto y dos cuartos
o un medio son igualmente buenas.
Así que en este caso particular
hay en realidad dos mejores aproximaciones en lugar de una.
Y es igualmente probable obtener el resultado uno
que el resultado dos.
Los otros dos resultados, cero y tres, que no ofrecen muy buenas
aproximaciones de theta cuando dividimos entre cuatro, sí aparecen con cierta probabilidad
que parece ser apenas
inferior al 10% en ambos casos.
Así que este procedimiento no es perfecto, pero sí nos proporciona información.
Y vale la pena destacar que
independientemente de theta, siempre tenemos garantizado obtener ya sea la mejor aproximación
o una de las dos mejores aproximaciones cuando hay empate, con una probabilidad que
parece ser justo por encima del 40%.
Y cuanto más cercano esté theta
a la aproximación, mayor es la probabilidad de ver el valor correspondiente de Y.
Y eso es una mejora bastante
significativa respecto a usar un solo qubit de control.
Este es de hecho el procedimiento de
estimación de fase cuando elegimos usar dos qubits de control.
Y lo que haremos a continuación es generalizar este
procedimiento de forma natural, donde no nos detenemos con
solo dos qubits de control
pero usamos tantos
control qubits como elijamos.
Y lo que veremos es que al
generalizar el procedimiento, añadiendo más control qubits, podremos obtener aproximaciones
cada vez más precisas de theta. Y ese será el procedimiento general
de estimación de fase.
Para generalizar el
procedimiento de estimación de fase de dos control qubits
a los que queramos, necesitamos entender
cómo se define la transformada de Fourier cuántica para otras dimensiones.
Y también necesitamos ver cómo puede implementarse
con un quantum circuit.
Aquí está la definición de la
transformada de Fourier cuántica cuando la dimensión es un
entero positivo arbitrario N.
Aquí pensamos en esta operación como una operación sobre un sistema cuyos estados clásicos son
de cero hasta N menos uno.
Y aquí la matriz que
describe esta operación se ha expresado usando
la notación directa.
También podemos describirla en términos de su acción
sobre los estados de la base estándar, para conectarla con
lo que ya vimos cuando N es igual a cuatro.
Así es como se ve
cuando N es igual a uno, que no es un caso muy interesante.
Aquí está para N igual a dos, y notarás que lo que obtenemos en este caso es una operación Hadamard.
Aquí está la transformada de Fourier cuántica
para N igual a tres.
Para N igual a cuatro, que
ya hemos visto.
Y como último ejemplo, aquí está cuando N es igual a ocho.
Al igual que antes
para el caso N igual a cuatro, estas son las matrices que asociamos con la transformada de Fourier discreta
para cada una de las dimensiones. Pero la llamamos
transformada de Fourier cuántica cuando queremos
pensarla como una operación cuántica.
A veces, por cierto, el factor inicial de uno sobre la raíz cuadrada de N no se incluye cuando pensamos en la transformada de Fourier discreta
como una matriz,
pero necesitamos ese factor aquí para asegurarnos de obtener una matriz unitaria.
También hay a veces un signo menos en cada uno de los exponentes, pero no siempre.
Es básicamente una preferencia personal que no cambia la naturaleza fundamental
de la transformada.
Pero en cualquier caso, definiremos la transformada de Fourier cuántica tal como está escrita aquí en la pantalla.
Hay una notación abreviada
muy útil que es común y la usaremos
un poco más adelante en la lección.
Y es definir un
número complejo omega N, como tenemos aquí.
Concretamente como e elevado a dos pi I sobre N, que también puede escribirse
usando senos y cosenos
como tenemos aquí mismo. A veces llamamos a este
número una raíz N de la unidad porque cuando lo elevamos
a la potencia N, obtenemos uno.
Aquí hay una figura que muestra algunos ejemplos.
Omega uno es igual a uno, omega dos es igual a menos uno, y omega cuatro es igual a I.
En general, para obtener omega N, podemos imaginar que dividimos el círculo unitario en N piezas iguales como si fuera una pizza compartida por N personas
y omega N está en la
esquina de la primera pieza, asumiendo que la otra esquina
de esa pieza está en uno.
Así que en particular, a medida que N
va siendo más y más grande, las piezas serán más y más pequeñas, y omega N se acercará
cada vez más a uno.
Y ahora, si usamos esa notación, podemos expresar la
transformada de Fourier cuántica de una forma un poco más limpia.
A veces esta notación
ayuda a mantener las cosas simples, como veremos que ocurre
un poco más adelante en la lección.
Hay una implementación eficiente con un quantum circuit de la transformada de Fourier cuántica
cuando N es una potencia de dos,
que ahora vamos a ver. Aunque tendemos a definir la
transformada de Fourier cuántica para cualquier dimensión N,
solo vamos a necesitarla
en el caso en que N sea una potencia de dos, para generalizar el
procedimiento de estimación de fase.
La implementación hará
uso de phase gates controladas, que se representan como
tenemos aquí en la pantalla.
Se ven como dos
controles conectados entre sí junto con un número que
es alfa en este caso.
Y la acción de este gate está descrita por la matriz que se muestra aquí.
Estas son literalmente
controlled phase gates, lo que significa que tenemos un control qubit que controla una phase gate.
Vimos las phase gates al principio en la lección uno.
Pero para las phase gates en particular, en realidad no importa
qué qubit es el control y cuál es el objetivo.
Y eso lo vimos en la lección dos, para el caso específico de una Z gate.
Y ahora que tenemos esa noción, podemos pasar a cómo puede implementarse
la transformada de Fourier cuántica.
La implementación es de naturaleza recursiva y quizás la forma más sencilla
de describirla en términos simples es dar un ejemplo que
pueda generalizarse fácilmente.
Así es como podemos hacerlo
cuando N es igual a 32.
Así que hay cinco qubits.
Para ser claros, estamos asociando los
estados de la base estándar de estos cinco qubits con los enteros entre cero y 31 usando notación binaria.
Lo primero que hacemos es realizar la transformada de Fourier cuántica
para N igual a 16 en todos los qubits excepto en
el qubit menos significativo,
que es el que está arriba. Y esa es la parte
recursiva de la construcción.
Para implementar esta operación, tenemos que seguir el mismo
patrón pero con un qubit menos.
Y en el caso base
tenemos un solo qubit, para el cual la transformada cuántica de Fourier es simplemente un gate Hadamard.
Una vez que aplicamos la QFT sobre todos los qubits excepto el de arriba, aplicamos un conjunto de controlled phase gates usando las fases indicadas en el diagrama.
Luego aplicamos un gate
Hadamard al qubit de arriba, y reordenamos los qubits un poco usando algunos swap gates.
Estos swap gates tienen el efecto de permutar cíclicamente los qubits, lo cual es necesario para que
la construcción funcione.
Podemos seguir exactamente el mismo patrón para otras elecciones de N,
siempre que sean potencias de dos, donde siempre empezamos los
controlled phase gates
con alpha igual a pi sobre
dos para el qubit de abajo y dividiendo por dos cada vez
moviéndonos hacia la izquierda en el diagrama
para obtener las fases siguientes. Ahora, no es para nada obvio
que esta construcción funcione.
Y no voy a explicar
por qué funciona en este video.
Si te interesa ver
los detalles de por qué funciona, puedes encontrarlos en el
contenido escrito de la lección.
Sin embargo, diré que
lo que se está aprovechando aquí es la estructura básica de
las transformadas discretas de Fourier
y de hecho es exactamente
la misma estructura que permite que la transformada
rápida de Fourier funcione.
Otra forma de decirlo es que si miramos la transformada rápida de Fourier, podemos pensarla en
términos de circuits cuánticos.
Y este es el circuit que obtenemos.
Entonces, ¿cuántos gates necesitamos en total para esta implementación?
Para averiguarlo, llamemos SM al número de gates que
necesitamos cuando tenemos M qubits.
Cuando M es igual a uno, solo necesitamos un único gate porque la QFT es simplemente una operación Hadamard en este caso.
Si M es al menos dos, entonces
estos son los gates que necesitamos.
Primero necesitamos SM menos uno gates para la transformada
cuántica de Fourier sobre M menos uno qubits, cualquiera que sea ese número.
También necesitamos M menos uno
controlled phase gates, M menos uno swap gates,
y un gate Hadamard adicional.
Entonces aquí hay una expresión
de SM en ambos casos: cuando M es igual a uno y
cuando M es al menos dos.
Este es un ejemplo de lo que se llama una relación de recurrencia, y
aparecen con mucha frecuencia en el análisis de algoritmos.
Esta en particular
resulta ser muy simple y tiene una expresión llamada
de forma cerrada, que podemos obtener sumando.
Para ser precisos, el valor de SM es la suma de los primeros M
enteros impares consecutivos, que es igual a M al cuadrado,
algo que quizás ya conocías o que tal vez
notaste en algún momento de tu vida.
Y resulta bastante fácil demostrar que esta fórmula es verdadera por inducción sobre M,
en caso de que te interese una demostración formal.
Y eso es todo. Podemos implementar la
transformada cuántica de Fourier sobre M qubits usando M al cuadrado gates.
Solo un par de observaciones
adicionales muy rápidas.
Primero, en realidad no
necesitamos todos los swap gates que he descrito.
Es posible efectivamente
desplazarlos todos al final, siempre que ajustemos sobre qué qubits actúan los controlled phase gates
de forma apropiada.
Y si hacemos eso, solo
necesitaremos M sobre dos swap gates en total, redondeando hacia abajo.
Seguiremos teniendo un costo cuadrático, pero el número de gates puede reducirse de esta manera de todas formas.
Y una última observación es que en realidad podemos reducir el costo aún más si estamos dispuestos a conformarnos con
una aproximación bastante buena.
Por ejemplo, cuando M crece, muchos de los controlled phase gates se parecen bastante a
la operación identidad,
y eliminar los que están
muy cerca de ella puede ahorrarnos bastante en gates mientras seguimos obteniendo
una aproximación bastante buena.
También es posible aproximar la transformada cuántica de Fourier
con circuits muy superficiales, es decir, con poca profundidad, en caso de que eso sea
algo que queramos hacer.
Y ahora que sabemos qué es la
transformada cuántica de Fourier para diferentes dimensiones, así como cómo puede implementarse cuando la dimensión es una potencia de dos,
podemos volver al
procedimiento de estimación de fase y ver cómo puede generalizarse cuando usamos algún número
arbitrario M de control qubits.
Así es como luce el procedimiento como circuit cuántico para
una elección arbitraria de M.
Tenemos M control qubits arriba, los cuales asumimos que están todos
inicializados al estado cero.
Aplicamos un gate
Hadamard a cada uno de ellos y luego cada uno se usa
como control qubit para aplicar alguna potencia de
la operación unitaria U,
donde duplicamos el número
de veces que se aplica U por cada control qubit.
Aquí en este diagrama lo he indicado incluyendo las potencias
de U dentro de los recuadros en lugar de mostrar el controlled U gate
aplicándose esa cantidad de veces, como una forma de tanto hacer
el diagrama más claro como de ahorrar espacio para
que quepa en la pantalla.
Ahora lo primero que hay que notar
sobre este procedimiento es que puede volverse muy costoso.
En particular, estamos
duplicando el número de veces que se aplica cada operación U
por cada control qubit.
Y si la forma en que hacemos esto es simplemente iterar un controlled U gate el número de veces que necesitemos,
vamos a obtener un circuit enorme. Será exponencialmente
grande en el número M.
Esa es una limitación importante en general, y en particular limita nuestra capacidad de obtener aproximaciones precisas
de los valores propios.
En el caso específico de la factorización, al que llegaremos en breve, resulta que tenemos mucha suerte y podemos usar un truco que nos permite
evitar este crecimiento exponencial del costo.
Pero en general para operaciones unitarias U
arbitrarias, esto no será posible y
pagaremos un precio alto
por aumentar el
número de control qubits.
No voy a hacer
un análisis detallado del circuit en este video; en cambio, solo mencionaré que hay una expresión bastante simple
para el estado
justo antes de las mediciones, que se muestra aquí en la pantalla.
A partir de ese estado podemos obtener una expresión para las probabilidades
de los distintos resultados, y tiene esta forma.
Y una vez que tenemos esta expresión,
podemos razonar sobre ella, y realmente esta expresión
es todo lo que necesitamos para continuar.
Como dije, no voy a entrar en
los detalles en este video, pero los puedes encontrar en el
contenido escrito de la lección, y resulta que no es
tan complicado en realidad,
así que échale un vistazo si te apetece. Si hacemos el análisis completo, encontramos que la situación
no es tan diferente
del caso M igual a dos, excepto que obtenemos más precisión.
En particular, podemos pensar
primero en la probabilidad de obtener la mejor aproximación o una de
las dos mejores aproximaciones,
que podemos expresar como se muestra aquí.
Puedes ignorar este subíndice de uno en el valor absoluto si quieres.
Es solo un símbolo que podemos
usar para recordarnos que estamos hablando de
aproximaciones en el círculo donde pensamos que theta igual a cero
y theta igual a uno son lo mismo. El punto aquí es que
estamos pensando en cualquier elección de Y que haga que Y sobre dos a la potencia M
sea lo más cercano posible a theta.
Y una vez más, igual que
teníamos para el caso M igual a dos, se garantiza que obtendremos este resultado Y con una probabilidad de al menos el 40%.
De hecho, la probabilidad es
de al menos cuatro sobre pi al cuadrado, que es un poco más del 40%.
10 no es una mala
aproximación de pi al cuadrado cuando tienes prisa.
Y eso es realmente notable. De lo que hablamos es de obtener la mejor
aproximación a theta como fracción Y sobre dos a la potencia M
donde Y es un entero. Y estamos obteniendo la
mejor aproximación con una probabilidad mayor al 40%.
También podemos pensar en
aproximaciones peores.
En concreto, imaginemos
que Y no es tan bueno, y más específicamente supongamos
que hay una mejor
aproximación a theta de la misma forma que se encuentra entre theta e Y sobre dos a la M,
lo cual se puede expresar
como está escrito en la pantalla.
En tal caso, la
probabilidad de obtener este Y será relativamente pequeña, como máximo el 25%.
En realidad será menor que eso, pero el 25% es lo que obtenemos de
un análisis bastante simple, aunque es suficiente.
Como ejemplo, aquí está la gráfica que obtenemos cuando usamos tres control
qubits en lugar de dos.
Esta vez solo estoy
graficando las probabilidades para los resultados tres, cuatro y cinco porque no quiero que la
figura quede muy desordenada.
Cuando theta es igual a
un medio, por ejemplo, se garantiza que obtendremos el resultado cuatro.
Y entonces tomamos nuestra
aproximación como cuatro octavos o un medio, porque dos a la
potencia tres es ocho.
Y en este caso tenemos exactamente razón. Y siempre que theta esté más cerca de un medio que, digamos, de tres
octavos,
obtenemos el resultado cuatro con una probabilidad mayor
que el resultado tres.
Y con probabilidad
nuevamente mayor al 40%.
Aquí está la gráfica cuando M es igual a cuatro. Y las curvas en realidad
se ven prácticamente idénticas, excepto que ahora hemos hecho zoom
con un factor de dos.
Así que ahora los resultados graficados incluyen siete, ocho y nueve, y tomamos la aproximación como uno de estos números
dividido por 16 en lugar de ocho.
Y mostraré una gráfica más donde aumentamos a M igual a cinco.
Y de nuevo vamos a hacer
zoom con un factor de dos.
Y aquí está. Una vez más las curvas se ven
prácticamente idénticas, pero estamos efectivamente
duplicando nuestra precisión.
Y como antes, obtenemos la mejor aproximación a theta con una probabilidad mayor al 40%.
Es bastante increíble. Pero si el 40% no es suficiente
como medida de confianza,
lo que podemos hacer es ejecutar el procedimiento un pequeño número de veces, y
tomar la moda de los resultados, es decir, el que
aparece con mayor frecuencia.
Y si hacemos eso, será muy probable que terminemos con una muy buena aproximación a theta.
Recuerda, por cierto, que cada vez que ejecutamos el
procedimiento de estimación de fase, el vector propio
sale sin cambios.
Así que está disponible para ejecutar el procedimiento
varias veces de esta forma.
En resumen, estamos recopilando
estadísticas sobre theta, y la clave está en que al hacer esto podemos obtener una aproximación muy precisa
a theta
con una confianza muy alta, y no necesitamos tantas iteraciones del procedimiento para lograrlo.
Y así es como funciona el
procedimiento de estimación de fase.
En la última parte de la lección, aplicaremos la técnica
de estimación de fase al problema de factorización de enteros.
Como mencioné al comienzo del video, la forma en que esto funciona es que consideramos un problema intermedio conocido como el problema de búsqueda de orden.
Veremos cómo podemos resolver
el problema de búsqueda de orden usando estimación de fase, y luego discutiremos brevemente cómo resolver el problema de búsqueda de orden
nos permite factorizar enteros de manera eficiente.
La segunda parte es completamente clásica y solo resumiré la
idea básica en este video.
Pero comencemos con el
problema de búsqueda de orden.
Primero, definamos una
notación conveniente.
Para todo entero positivo N, definimos ZN como los enteros
del cero al N menos uno.
Así que, por ejemplo, Z uno tiene un
único elemento que es el cero, Z dos tiene los elementos cero y uno,
Z tres tiene los elementos cero,
uno y dos, y así sucesivamente.
Entonces ZN es un conjunto.
Pero también podemos pensarlo
como algo más que un conjunto. Podemos pensar en operaciones aritméticas como la suma y la multiplicación en ZN
definiéndolas módulo N.
Por ejemplo, supongamos
que N es igual a siete.
Tenemos que tres y cinco
son elementos de Z siete y si los multiplicamos obtenemos 15
que deja un residuo de
uno al dividir por siete.
A veces expresamos esto escribiendo que tres por cinco es
congruente con uno módulo siete, como se escribe aquí.
Pero también podemos escribir simplemente que tres por cinco es igual a uno.
Por supuesto, tres por cinco
normalmente no es igual a uno, es igual a 15.
Pero cuando está claro que
estamos trabajando en Z siete, es decir, que la multiplicación
está definida módulo siete,
podemos simplemente escribir que
tres por cinco es igual a uno.
Ahora bien, entre los elementos
de ZN para cualquier N positivo, algunos tendrán
MCD igual a uno con N
y otros no. Y los elementos que sí tienen MCD igual a uno con N son especiales.
y escribimos ZN estrella para referirnos al conjunto formado solo por esos elementos.
Así que, por ejemplo, aquí está Z 21 estrella.
entre los elementos de Z 21, que son 21 en total, resulta que 12 de ellos tienen MCD igual a uno
con 21 y el resto no.
En particular, cada vez que
tenemos un elemento de Z 21 que es divisible por tres
o por siete, lo omitimos.
Hay varias razones
por las que este conjunto es especial, y una de ellas es que cada vez que tenemos un elemento de ZN estrella
y consideramos las
potencias enteras positivas de ese número, siempre acabaremos
llegando al número uno,
donde, igual que antes, estamos hablando de multiplicación módulo N.
la menor potencia entera positiva que nos da uno se llama
el orden de ese elemento.
Por ejemplo, pensemos en el elemento A igual a cuatro en Z 21 estrella.
cuatro por cuatro es 16, que no es igual a uno módulo 21, pero si multiplicamos por cuatro una vez más,
obtenemos 64, y 64 módulo
21 es igual a uno.
Entonces el orden de cuatro módulo 21 es tres.
Llegar a uno de esta manera siempre ocurre para todos los elementos de ZN estrella.
Y por cierto, nunca
ocurre para los elementos de ZN que no están en ZN estrella.
Así que tener MCD igual a
uno con N de esta forma es tanto necesario como
suficiente para que esto ocurra.
Y para terminar con el
ejemplo de N igual a 21, aquí están las menores
potencias enteras positivas para las que esto funciona para
cada elemento de Z 21 estrella,
y cada una puede verificarse una por una.
Y ahora podemos enunciar el
problema de búsqueda de orden, que consiste simplemente en encontrar el orden de un elemento dado en ZN estrella.
Para ser precisos, la entrada son
dos enteros positivos A y N para los cuales el MCD es igual a uno,
y la salida es el
menor entero positivo R tal que A elevado a la R es
congruente con uno módulo N,
o de manera equivalente, el
menor entero positivo R para el cual A elevado a la R es igual a uno.
Suponiendo que hacemos la aritmética en ZN.
Se cree que este es un
problema computacionalmente difícil; no se conoce ningún algoritmo clásico eficiente
para resolverlo.
Y como discutiremos, el problema es al menos tan difícil como
la factorización de enteros, en el sentido de que si tuviéramos un algoritmo para resolver la búsqueda de orden,
podríamos usar ese algoritmo para resolver el problema de
factorización de enteros de manera eficiente.
De hecho, también funciona al revés, es decir, si tienes un algoritmo para factorizar, puedes usarlo para resolver
el problema de encontrar el orden.
Así que los dos problemas son
en cierto sentido equivalentes en cuanto a su
dificultad computacional.
Ahora veremos cómo podemos resolver
el problema de encontrar el orden en un ordenador cuántico
usando la estimación de fase.
Para establecer una conexión entre los problemas, imaginemos que tenemos un sistema cuyo conjunto de estados clásicos es AN.
Para cualquier elección de un elemento A en ZN estrella, definiremos una operación
MA como la que tenemos aquí.
En palabras, lo que hace MA es multiplicar por A, y aquí la multiplicación es modular N.
Y durante el resto de esta lección, siempre debes pensar en
las expresiones dentro de los kets como calculadas modular N,
simplemente para mantener las cosas simples y no tener que seguir
escribiendo mod N una y otra vez.
Esta es una operación unitaria, pero eso solo es cierto
porque A está en ZN estrella.
Si el MCD de A y N no es uno, esta operación no será unitaria.
Aquí hay un ejemplo. Si N es igual a 15 y A es igual a dos, que está en Z 15 estrella, entonces
esta es la acción de M dos.
Y si examinas este
ejemplo durante unos momentos, verás que lo que ocurre es que los elementos de ZN simplemente se permutan con esta acción.
Así que es tanto determinista como unitaria, lo que quiere decir que, como matriz, MA es una matriz de permutación.
Y aquí está la idea principal. Los valores propios de MA están
muy estrechamente relacionados
con el orden de A. Y usando la estimación de fase para aproximar estos
valores propios con suficiente precisión
podemos determinar el orden de A. Entonces, ¿cuáles son exactamente los vectores propios y los valores propios de MA?
Bueno, no vamos a necesitarlos todos, solo necesitamos algunos de ellos.
Empecemos con un ejemplo sencillo.
Aquí hay un vector propio de MA, lo hemos llamado psi cero, y viene dado por la
suma del ket uno, el ket a,
el ket A al cuadrado, y así sucesivamente hasta el ket A a la potencia R menos uno, todo dividido por la raíz cuadrada de R
para convertirlo en un vector unitario. Aquí R es el orden de A.
Y reservaré la
letra R para el orden de A durante el resto de la lección.
Así que cuando veas R, ese es el orden de A para
cualquier A del que estemos hablando.
El valor propio asociado
con este vector propio es uno.
Y podemos verificarlo
aplicando MA a este vector para ver qué obtenemos.
MA multiplica por A, así que
solo necesitamos aumentar cada uno de los exponentes en
uno y esto es lo que obtenemos.
Pero el orden de A es R, así que A a la potencia R es igual a uno.
Y podemos hacer esa sustitución.
Pero ese es el mismo vector
con el que empezamos. Todo lo que hemos hecho es
reorganizar los kets, pero estamos tomando la suma, así que
esto no cambia nada.
Así que MA por psi cero es igual a psi cero.
Por tanto, es un vector propio de
MA con valor propio uno.
Ese es un ejemplo muy simple
de un vector propio y para identificar más de ellos, recordemos la misma notación que teníamos antes en la lección.
Omega R es el número complejo
sobre el círculo unitario que obtenemos tomando E a la
potencia de dos por pi por i
dividido por R. La última vez teníamos una N en lugar de una R, pero sigue funcionando igual
para R en lugar de N.
Necesitamos este número porque
va a aparecer en los otros vectores propios
de MA que identificaremos.
Y ahora que hemos recordado esa notación, podemos observar que este
vector llamado psi uno también es un vector propio de MA.
Es similar a psi cero, tenemos exactamente los mismos kets y los estamos sumando y
dividiendo por la raíz de R.
Pero esta vez tenemos varias fases multiplicando cada uno de los kets.
Omega R a la menos uno para A, omega R a la menos dos para A al cuadrado, y así sucesivamente hasta omega R a
la potencia menos R menos uno
para A a la potencia R menos uno. Así que la potencia de omega R
es siempre menos uno multiplicado por cualquier potencia de A
que aparezca dentro del ket.
No lo voy a explicar en detalle, pero sí se muestra en pantalla por si quieres volver a ver el video y pausarlo cuando sea necesario.
Pero si hacemos la multiplicación y simplificamos de nuevo usando el hecho de que A a la potencia R es igual a uno
así como el hecho muy importante de que omega a la potencia R es igual a uno, lo que encontraremos es que
de nuevo tenemos un vector propio de MA.
Esta vez, al hacer la simplificación, tendremos que extraer un factor de omega R para ver que efectivamente tenemos un vector propio
y que ese vector de omega R representa el valor propio asociado con este vector propio.
Así que ese es un segundo par
vector propio-valor propio de NA.
Podemos identificar vectores propios adicionales usando exactamente el mismo razonamiento, y de hecho, si simplemente reemplazamos omega R
por omega R a la potencia J para cada J entre cero y R menos uno, siempre obtendremos un vector propio,
y el valor propio asociado será omega R a la potencia J.
Así que esto en realidad incluye
psi cero y psi uno, que ya vimos,
así como R menos dos pares adicionales de vector propio-valor propio.
Todos funcionan básicamente de la misma manera, y para verificarlos, solo necesitamos saber que A a la potencia R es igual a uno
así como omega R a
la potencia R es igual a uno.
Hay otros vectores propios de MA, como el estado cero por ejemplo, pero no nos van a ser útiles y no necesitamos preocuparnos por ellos.
Solo necesitamos preocuparnos por psi cero hasta psi R menos uno.
Enfoquémonos en psi uno por un momento, solo para intentar entender por qué nos importan estos vectores propios
y qué nos pueden decir
sobre el orden R, que es lo que estamos tratando de encontrar.
Suponiendo que se nos da
el vector propio psi uno, podemos intentar determinar
R de la siguiente manera.
Primero, realizamos la estimación
de fase sobre este vector propio usando un quantum circuit que
implementa la operación MA.
Lo que obtenemos es una aproximación a theta, que en este caso es uno sobre R.
Y segundo, como estamos buscando R y tenemos una
aproximación a uno sobre R, lo natural es
calcular el recíproco
y redondearlo al
entero más cercano. Tenemos que redondear así
porque R debe ser un entero.
Pero no tenemos uno sobre R de manera exacta, solo tenemos una aproximación.
Pero si la aproximación es suficientemente buena, obtendremos R al redondear,
que es lo que estamos buscando.
Y ahora la pregunta es: ¿cuánta precisión necesitamos para determinar correctamente R calculando el recíproco y redondeando?
O en otras palabras, ¿qué tan precisa debe ser nuestra
aproximación para que todo esto funcione?
Bueno, resulta que sí necesitamos una aproximación bastante precisa.
Por ejemplo, no podemos
permitirnos confundir uno sobre R con uno sobre R más uno, o uno sobre R menos uno, por ejemplo.
En esas dos fracciones, uno sobre R más uno y
uno sobre R menos uno están bastante cerca de uno
sobre R cuando R es grande.
Pero aunque sí necesitamos una
aproximación bastante precisa, no necesitamos una aproximación
ridículamente precisa, y se puede demostrar que
si nuestra aproximación
satisface la desigualdad que
tenemos aquí en pantalla, entonces al redondear
obtendremos la respuesta correcta.
No voy a intentar argumentar eso en este video, pero se demuestra en el material
escrito de la lección por si te interesan los detalles.
Y si esa es la precisión
que buscamos, entonces es suficiente usar un
cierto número de qubits de control en el procedimiento de estimación de fase
igual a dos veces
la longitud de N más uno.
Donde, como vimos en las lecciones anteriores, la longitud de N es el número de bits que necesitamos para expresar N en binario.
Por cierto, si nos conformamos
con obtener la mejor aproximación con probabilidad de al menos el 40% y no intentamos
aumentar nuestra confianza
como describí antes, entonces en realidad no necesitamos el más uno.
Pero en cualquier caso, tenemos que el número
de qubits de control que necesitamos es lineal en la longitud de N
escrito como cadena binaria.
Hemos visto que si tenemos
el vector propio psi uno, podemos usar la estimación de fase para encontrar R, siempre que usemos suficiente precisión.
Desafortunadamente, no es tan fácil obtener este vector propio.
Así que hagámonos una pregunta diferente.
Supongamos que no tenemos psi uno, sino que tenemos psi
para una elección aleatoria de J.
¿Podemos seguir descubriendo cuál es R? O al menos, ¿podemos
descubrir algo sobre R?
Y la respuesta es sí, podemos descubrir algo
sobre R, al menos en promedio.
Lo que podemos hacer es intentar
determinar J sobre R usando un método muy similar
al que acabamos de ver,
pero con una diferencia clave.
Primero, haremos exactamente lo
mismo que hicimos antes, que es ejecutar el procedimiento de estimación
de fase sobre el vector propio psi J.
Y lo que obtendremos es una
aproximación a J sobre R, a diferencia de uno sobre R,
que es lo que teníamos antes.
Pero ahora tenemos un pequeño problema, porque calcular el
recíproco no nos dará R, sino R sobre J.
Y por cierto, no estamos
asumiendo que sabemos qué es J; simplemente se nos da psi J para un J aleatorio,
y no se nos dice cuál es J. Entonces, ¿qué podemos hacer?
Bueno, resulta que hay un conocido
algoritmo clásico que puede ayudarnos, llamado el
algoritmo de fracciones continuas.
Y lo que este algoritmo puede hacer es tomar nuestra aproximación
Y sobre dos a la M y decirnos qué fracción U sobre V,
escrita en términos mínimos, y donde U y V son ambos
enteros menores que N, es la más cercana a nuestra aproximación.
Es un algoritmo verdaderamente fascinante, y si te interesa, definitivamente deberías consultarlo.
Está muy estrechamente relacionado con el algoritmo de Euclides para
calcular MCD, de hecho.
Pero no diré nada
más sobre él en este video.
El punto es que si tenemos una buena
aproximación a alguna fracción cuyos numerador y
denominador no son demasiado grandes,
el algoritmo puede recuperar la fracción, y eso es lo que estamos haciendo aquí.
Y ahora nos quedamos exactamente con
la misma pregunta que antes: ¿cuánta precisión necesitamos?
Y resulta que
exactamente la misma cota que teníamos antes funciona en este caso.
Y por lo tanto, elegir M exactamente
de la misma manera que antes también funciona aquí.
Esto no nos dice necesariamente R.
Lo que aprenderemos, si usamos
suficiente precisión, es J sobre R, pero eso será una
fracción en términos mínimos.
Así que podríamos tener mala suerte en el sentido de que esta elección aleatoria de J podría tener factores comunes con R,
y estarán ocultos para nosotros. En el peor caso, por ejemplo, podríamos obtener J igual a cero y no aprenderemos absolutamente nada.
Pero ese es literalmente el único
caso en el que no aprendemos nada.
En general, al menos
obtendremos un factor no trivial de R, y si somos capaces de tomar muestras aleatorias
y obtener psi J para distintas elecciones de J, podemos de hecho recuperar
R con alta probabilidad calculando el mínimo común múltiplo
de todos los denominadores
que observamos. Y en realidad esto no
requiere muchas muestras en absoluto.
En conclusión, algunas elecciones de J ocultarán factores de R, pero las elecciones aleatorias de J
no podrán ocultar los
factores de R por mucho tiempo.
Así que esa es la idea. Queda por considerar la implementación y en particular determinar
cuánto cuesta.
La esencia de la idea, para calcular el orden de un
elemento dado A en ZN estrella, es aplicar el procedimiento de estimación de fase
a la operación MA.
Veamos cuál es
el costo de hacer esto en función de la longitud del N mayúscula, que denotaré por n minúscula.
Aquí hay un circuit para la estimación de fase. Vamos a necesitar n minúscula qubits en la parte inferior del circuit
para codificar elementos de ZN en binario. Así que tenemos N qubits de control arriba y n minúscula qubits abajo,
lo cual es conveniente porque eso coincide con los nombres que
usamos antes en la lección.
Para contar el
número de gates que necesitamos para todo el circuit, centrémonos primero en el costo de las operaciones unitarias controladas.
Si usamos las técnicas
de la lección anterior, la lección seis, podemos implementar MA usando un gran O de n minúscula al cuadrado gates
usando algoritmos clásicos eficientes para la aritmética modular N.
Omitiré los detalles en este video, pero como varias otras
cosas de las que he hablado, puedes leer más al respecto en el material escrito de la lección.
Sin embargo, no es suficiente
con implementar solo MA.
También necesitamos implementar MA al cuadrado, MA a la cuarta potencia, a
la octava potencia, y así sucesivamente
hasta MA a una potencia que es exponencial en M.
Y sabemos que necesitaremos que M sea lineal en n minúscula
para obtener suficiente precisión.
Esto es una gran preocupación,
y lo mencioné antes.
Si fuéramos a implementar las potencias
de MA simplemente iterando MA, tendríamos un problema porque todas esas iteraciones de MA
incurrirían en un costo exponencial.
Afortunadamente, podemos usar un truco para evitar este aumento de costo.
Lo que podemos hacer es lo siguiente, para cada potencia K que necesitamos.
Primero, calculamos A a
la potencia K, módulo N.
Este es el problema de exponenciación modular que mencioné en la lección seis.
Y puede resolverse eficientemente. Y esto es algo que podemos hacer con un ordenador clásico.
Este cálculo no
necesita ser realizado por un circuit cuántico en absoluto.
Así que llamemos B al resultado.
Entonces B es un elemento de ZN estrella.
Y segundo, en lugar de MA a la potencia K, simplemente usamos un circuit para MB.
Y eso es todo. B es solo algún elemento de ZN estrella, así que el costo de implementar MB
es un gran O de n minúscula al cuadrado.
En pocas palabras, lo que estamos haciendo es exponenciar en ZN en lugar de exponenciar
un circuit cuántico.
Pero la operación real que
obtenemos es la misma de cualquier manera. Es simplemente multiplicación por A, K veces.
Esto es en realidad una especie de milagro. Y no seríamos capaces de
resolver el problema de encontrar el orden o factorizar enteros eficientemente
con un ordenador cuántico
si no fuera por esto.
Y ahora que sabemos que cada una de las
operaciones unitarias controladas, incluidas las potencias, pueden implementarse
a un costo de gran O de n al cuadrado, podemos contar el número total
de gates que necesitamos.
Tenemos N gates Hadamard, y como M es igual
a gran O de n minúscula, el costo es gran O de n minúscula.
Tenemos M operaciones unitarias controladas que cada una tiene un costo de gran O de N al cuadrado.
Así que el costo total aquí
es gran O de N al cubo.
Y finalmente, la transformada de Fourier cuántica tiene un costo de gran O de n al cuadrado.
Así que el costo total es gran O de N al cubo.
En particular, vemos que incluso con nuestro
truco de exponenciación modular, el costo de las operaciones
unitarias controladas domina.
Pero aun así, el costo
es polinómico en n minúscula.
También se requieren algunos
cálculos clásicos, como calcular las exponenciaciones modulares y ejecutar el algoritmo de
fracciones continuas,
pero esos cálculos
también tienen costo polinómico. Y de hecho, también pueden realizarse en gran O de N al cubo operaciones.
Solo queda un problema pendiente, y es que necesitamos hacernos con uno de estos vectores propios.
¿Cómo podemos hacer esto?
La solución es en realidad muy sencilla. No ejecutamos el circuit
sobre un vector propio.
Simplemente lo ejecutamos sobre el estado uno, es decir, la codificación
binaria del número uno, que estamos tratando
como un elemento de ZN.
Así que hagamos ese
reemplazo en el diagrama.
La razón por la que esto funciona es por esta ecuación de aquí.
El estado ket uno es de
hecho una superposición uniforme de los R vectores propios de los que
hemos estado hablando.
Y eso no es inmediatamente obvio, pero si calculas la
suma, deberías obtener ket uno.
Y si ejecutamos el circuit sobre este estado, la salida que obtendremos
será exactamente la misma que si hubiésemos elegido J al azar
y ejecutado el procedimiento sobre
el vector propio psi J.
De nuevo, eso no es obvio, pero un análisis revela que es cierto.
Y finalmente, eso es todo. Tenemos un
algoritmo cuántico eficiente para encontrar el orden.
Queda una parte muy breve
de la lección y tiene que ver con la relación entre la factorización de enteros
y la búsqueda de orden.
Mencioné que si podemos resolver el problema de búsqueda de orden de manera eficiente, entonces también podemos factorizar
enteros de manera eficiente.
Y quiero explicarte muy brevemente la idea principal de cómo funciona esto.
Es completamente clásico. Esta parte en realidad no tiene
nada que ver con la computación cuántica.
Aquí hay un método para encontrar
un factor no trivial de un entero positivo N dado.
Y por cierto, este método solo funciona cuando N es un número impar y no es un número primo
elevado a una potencia.
Esos dos casos en los que N
es par o una potencia de primo se pueden manejar por separado.
Existen métodos clásicos eficientes tanto para detectar como para
manejar esos dos casos.
Este método es probabilístico. Puede fallar, pero la
probabilidad de fallo será como máximo la mitad,
y podemos simplemente ejecutarlo
varias veces de forma independiente para reducir la probabilidad
de error de forma exponencialmente rápida.
Primero, elegimos A entre
dos y N menos uno al azar, de manera uniforme.
Luego calculamos el MCD de A y N.
Y si el MCD resulta
ser mayor que uno, entonces hemos tenido una suerte increíble.
El MCD será un factor de N y simplemente podemos mostrarlo y detenernos.
De lo contrario, el algoritmo continúa y ahora sabemos que A pertenece a ZN estrella.
Y ahora calculamos el orden de A, que es donde necesitamos una computadora cuántica.
O quizás tengamos una forma diferente
de calcular el orden. Al algoritmo realmente no
le importa de dónde venga, pero la única forma que conocemos
de hacerlo eficientemente
es con una computadora cuántica.
Si el orden de R es par, entonces calculamos el MCD de
A elevado a R sobre dos menos uno con N.
Y si ese MCD es mayor que uno, entonces de nuevo tenemos un factor de N, así que lo mostramos y nos detenemos.
De lo contrario, el algoritmo ha fallado. Y en ese caso,
podemos volver al principio y elegir un A diferente
y esperar un mejor
resultado la próxima vez.
Y eso es todo. Y por cierto, una vez que
encontramos un factor de N, podemos recurrir tanto sobre ese factor
como dividirlo por ese factor hasta obtener la factorización prima de N.
¿Por qué debería funcionar esto?
Bien, hay dos puntos principales. El primero es que como A elevado a R es congruente con uno módulo N,
tenemos que N divide A
elevado a R menos uno.
Esas dos afirmaciones
son en realidad equivalentes. Esta es la definición de mod N que encontrarás en los libros de teoría de números.
Segundo, si R es par, entonces esta ecuación que
tenemos aquí es verdadera.
Esta es la conocida fórmula
de la diferencia de cuadrados.
De hecho, la ecuación es válida para todo R, pero necesitamos que R sobre dos sea
un entero en el paso cuatro.
Y así, si juntamos los dos hechos, vemos que todo factor primo de N debe dividir una de las dos
expresiones entre paréntesis,
porque esa es la única forma
en que N puede dividir el producto.
Ahora bien, podría ser que todos
los factores primos de N dividan la primera
expresión entre paréntesis y no la segunda, pero para nuestro A aleatorio,
eso no es muy probable. Y entonces cuando calculamos
el MCD en el paso cuatro, es probable que obtengamos el producto
de algunos de los factores primos
de N, pero no todos.
Analizar esto con rigor
requiere algo de teoría de números, pero es teoría de números bastante básica.
Así que si te parece interesante la teoría de números
y quieres aprender más, intenta desarrollar este análisis.
Trabajar en cosas como esta es una excelente manera de aprender más, pero te lo dejo a ti.
Y eso es el final de la lección. En esta lección, cubrimos
el problema de estimación de fase, cómo podemos resolverlo eficientemente
en una computadora cuántica,
y cómo podemos aplicar la solución para obtener un
algoritmo cuántico de coste polinomial para la factorización de enteros.
Espero que te unas a mí en la próxima lección, que trata sobre el
algoritmo de búsqueda cuántica de Grover.
Hasta la próxima. ¡Adiós!